مره اخرى وغير ابه لردود الفعل الغاضبه
التي اثارها اقتحامه الاول بعد توليه منصب
وزير في الحكومه الحاليه يتقدم بنجفير
اقتحامات المستوطنين للمسجد الاقصى وهذه
المره ضمن الاحتفال بذكرى احتلال الشطر
الشرقي من مدينه القدس
امعان في تهويد القدس واعتداء سافر على
مقدساتها هكذا وصف الجانب الفلسطيني تعمد
الحكومه الاسرائيليه اقامه احتفالها بذكرى
احتلال القدس على هذا النحو وقد حذرت
الجهات الرسميه والفصائل الفلسطينيه من
تداعيات التصعيد الاسرائيلي المتواصل في
المدينه تحاول اسرائيل تغيير هويه القدس
وستفشل تماما في ذلك ونحن نرى ما يجري هو
ليس استفزازا للشعب الفلسطيني بل الامه
العربيه وخاصه للقمه العربيه التي انعقدت
قبل ايام هذا تحدي سافر للامه العربيه
وتحدي سافر للقانون الدولي والاشتراضي
الدوليه رسائل سياسيه جمه ترسلها الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بل الحكومات المتعاقبه
للفلسطينيين وللعالم العربي والمجتمع
الدولي بشان القدس المحتله والاصرار على
مواصله احتلالها ذلك الى جانب ما يصفه
كثيرون بمساعي اسرائيل المتواصله من اجل
تحويل الصراع الى صراع ديني لكن من جهه
اخرى لا يمكن اغفال استغلال هذا الصراع
لحل ازمات الحكومه الداخليه وهذا يمر ايضا
وفقا لرؤيتهم عبر انتهاك المسجد الاقصى في
ظل حكومه توصف بانها الاشد تطرفا تزداد
وتيره العمل على تهويد القدس المحتله
وانتهاك مقدساتها مشروع بدا بعد احتلال
القدس ويستند بالاساس كما يقول
الفلسطينيون الى تزوير تاريخ المدينه
وتعزيز الاستيطان فيها مقابل تهجيرهم منها
نجوان سمري الجزيره القدس المحتله